welcome back let's talk do's and don'ts
for becoming a homeowner Rocky spoke
with Clark County Credit Union the
sponsors of this segment to get their
tips
now you know obviously getting a home
buying a home is an exciting time but it
can be a little scary for some people so
where should they start let's just start
there the best place to start would be
to speak to your loan officer
um they're going to have kind of the
best idea of the programs and guidelines
and look over your situation to kind of
set you on the path but just in general
savings is a good point you're going to
need some funds one way or the other you
know for down payment closing costs
um your earnest money deposit even after
closing you might be furniture that you
want to buy or appliances repairs or
Renovations so it's good to start
setting aside that money in advance we
have a program exclusive to Clark County
Credit Union we call the home now it
allows for two percent down on a
conventional loan which is pretty
stellar because most conventional loans
require at least three percent down and
that's if you're a first time home buyer
uh if you're not a first-time home buyer
they want five percent down so two
percent is a significant savings and you
can use those extra funds to kind of
help you with those other items you
might need oh so much to consider so
much to learn
um right right anything else that you
guys uh would tell people to start
preparing for as they as they enter this
process definitely I mean you you
definitely want to you know review your
credit credit scores and the important
part of uh you know getting approved to
buy a home so you know and remember for
a mortgage loan we require all three
bureaus uh for the credit report not
just one so make sure you're looking at
all that keep you know your payments all
on time make sure that the uh the bet
you know the limit on your credit cards
is it more than like 50 of the balance
you know or I'm sorry fifty percent of
the limit is what I meant to say and
then the other thing is also watch out
for big car payments that can be a major
hurdle like if you're in the market for
a home in a car get the home first
because the dealership will find a way
to get you in the car you know a
mortgage underwriter will say no
that's that's really good advice that is
a great reminder now if everyone has you
know these things lined up and
everything is in place because they've
been working with you guys
um you know what type of mortgage should
they sign up for they're awesome yeah I
mean there are all sorts of mortgage
options and it can be overwhelming to
you know the first time home buyer even
someone who's had a home before
and they all kind of sound the same you
know Freddie Mac
FHA VA you know there's no way so you
want to talk to like one of the
experienced loan officers here at Clark
County Credit Union they'll review your
situation and kind of set you up with
the program that best meets your goals
okay and when we call you guys as we're
you know thinking about buying a home or
ready to buy our first home what is the
first step
I'd say you know give uh you know Clark
County Credit Union a call or you can go
online uh through
ccculv.org on there you can review all
the mortgage products we offer we have
all sorts we even have uh you know land
and construction loans if you want to
build your own home plus that two
percent down option so it's a good
program so whatever your you know your
dream home goals are we can help you get
there thank you to the Clark County
Credit Union for sponsoring this segment
for more information call
702-228-2228 or visit
ccculv.org don't forget they do have a
special offer for you it's the cccu home
now program it offers a two percent down
payment for qualified buyers